Now were going to talk about something that's very important for
decision trees, and that is entropy.
Entropy is basically the thing that controls how a decision tree
decides where to split the data.
So, entropy is this very powerful thing.
What's the definition?
It's a measure of impurity in a bunch of examples.
Let me show you what I mean.
Sebastian self-driving car data, we have the grade and
the bumpiness of the terrain, like we did before.
But, let's suppose that there's a new variable, a new feature now
that we're going to take into account, and that is a speed limit.
Remember, the question was whether the car can drive fast or slow.
So, if there's a speed limit, it shouldn't be driving very fast.
So remember, before we had data that looked like this,
where he had the bumpiness and the grade.
Now, let's suppose we had the speed limit and the grade.
And, let's suppose the speed limit worked like this.
If the speed limit was in force, you're in this half of the data.
And the, if the speed limit is not in force,
you can go at whatever the speed you like, you're in this half of the data,
the lower half of the scatter plot here.
So then, when the speed limit is in effect, doesn't matter what grade it is,
everything's going to be slow.
Whereas, when the speed limit is not in effect,
you still have to go slow when it's too steep, but
now you can still go fast if it's flat enough, if the terrain is good.